kpmg has bought bitcoin and ethereum and
put it on its corporate treasury that's
right one of the big four accounting
firms going all in on crypto assets now
this is important to understand kpmg is
a network of various entities around the
world the us entity is different than
the canadian entity etc and the canadian
entity has decided to breach the wall
they've bought bitcoin and ethereum put
that on their corporate treasury now
it'd be important to understand the
canadians have been much more friendly
towards crypto assets then let's say
here in the united states obviously
there's a bitcoin spot etf in canada and
there is not one in the united states i
don't know how much that played into
this decision but it's definitely
noteworthy on top of that why the hell
is kpmg buying bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies well here's exactly
what they're saying they're saying that
crypto is a maturing asset class
investors such as hedge funds and family
offices large insurers and pension funds
are increasingly gaining exposure to
these assets traditional financial
services such as banks financial
advisors and brokerages are exploring
offering products and services also this
investment reflects the kpmg's belief
that institutional adoption of crypto
assets and blockchain technology will
continue to grow and become a regular
part of the asset mix now that sounds
great sounds like a bunch of corporate
speak it sounds like oh we believe in
crypto assets but there's a much much
bigger story here if you're one of the
big four accounting firms if you also
provide tax and advisory services as
well you've got to differentiate you got
to somehow make sure that corporations
know you are the leader they should come
to you for those services that's exactly
what kpmg is doing here if you look and
see how they're talking about it the
next quote we have shows exactly where
kpmg is going with this having gone
through this process ourselves now we're
confident we can guide clients and
prospective clients through the process
of crypto asset treasury allocation our
investment allows us to share our
journey our experiences our challenges
with them so that we can help them
navigate the crypto asset world kpmg
believes in bitcoin and ethereum kpmg
probably thinks that they're going to
make a little money on this but really
kpmg is doing this because they want to
go to clients and say we're the only one
of the big four firms that's actually
done it ourselves we've gone through the
process and just how difficult is that
process well here's what they described
in terms of exactly what they had to do
they established a governance committee
to provide oversight and approve the
treasury allocation that included
stakeholders from finance risk
management advisory audit and tax and
they also undertook and completed a
rigorous risk assessment process that
included a review of regulatory
reputational and custodial risks kpmg
specialists also assessed the tax and
accounting implications of the
transaction now of course kpmg they hang
their hat on being rigorous they do lots
of diligence and they can come and they
can give you advice for a nice hefty fee
and that's exactly what they're doing
here kpmg yesterday just decided to take
a step forward they want to be the
leader in crypto advice whether it's tax
whether it's regulation or advisory
services kpmg thinks that they're better
than their competitors and the best way
to show that is to go through the
process do the diligence and eventually
buy bitcoin and ethereum and put it on
their balance sheet kudos to kpmg
they're the first i don't think they'll
be the last